could we do without the hat no yeah
because the photo is out
all right john john uh where'd you grow
up where are you from
memphis tennessee memphis and uh tell me
about how you grew up you had both your
parents
yeah well with the knot you know what
i'm saying uh
they were always gone a lot uh
they when they were there though they
were they were good to us you know but
and then my dad he wasn't there he was
never really there but it was just
mainly my mom
and my older sister me and my sister she
kind of raised us
you know she was the one you know that
kept us
together you know because you know the
siblings or whatever
what what was mom doing that your sister
raised you man i don't tell him man i'll
run the streets man
let's see your mom was she'd always lie
you know we all knew what really going
on you know she
you know she's out there prostituting
and you know whatever
but uh she sold uh drugs you know mainly
uh
i mean when i got older i was you know
it was crack and then uh
you know she lied to us she made us seem
like it was an illusion or whatever but
you know
like we're all on vacation that her dad
was working you know she would always
just lie to us
make it seem like but how would you
describe your childhood
ah i mean
if i look at it now i mean uh
it's just part of life i mean you just
get what you dealt you know what i mean
he's kind of
it is what it is you know uh i mean i
don't
regret it i don't wish i had a different
one i mean it is
maybe i would have turned out the same
way you know maybe it was just it's me
that was
the drug but i know that had to help but
i've seen people grow up and
you know nice homes nice family and
still be out here
you know how far are you in school uh
almost eighth grade beginning eighth
grade
yeah i think i've went like maybe
a week or two and then uh started
hanging out with these
these guys i started selling drugs too
man the drugs got more important to me
you know i just was making a little
money you know i thought i was just
the doughboy you know the cool complex
oh boy i had a car i was already having
a ride you know and
just the drugs man i was just pushing
and pushing
and the money was always there you got
into drugs very early
oh yeah yeah i started uh i used
the first time i wanted to say i was
about 12 years old
it was uh there were some xanax i
remember like it was yesterday
they uh my mom always had them and uh
i remember she was always stumping up
saying i'm gonna tell you anything in
xanax you know
every time something got crazy or
something she's always saying i need to
take this xanax so
now i thought it was just a little blue
pill or whatever but anyway i popped a
couple and i
started out i'd snagged him something
she had so many i would just
you know i'd keep them on me and i i got
to where i was addicted to him man i was
eating
yeah i'm just eating a lot of them today
what is your joke today
uh i got an opi addiction these days uh
i was actually
my longest time clean man was like uh
almost six months and then i ended up
getting shot
i was uh working for this guy doing the
best i've ever done in my life i was
doing remodeling
and making good money and a call came up
and i needed extra money
and uh i had to go these guys i worked
with
whatever you know i got a car boosting
business whatever
anyway i went and did this job
and uh pulled up and bad situation went
bad i got shot
and for the pain or whatever i wouldn't
have the bullet taken out they gave me a
very very weak pain pill
so uh anyway this guy pulled up say hey
man i got some you know i got some dope
and i've done it before
i am [ __ ] you know give me something
here i am today it's been two and a half
months later and i've been on
strong man i've tried quitting twice
already
you know fentanyl now yeah vietnam
mm-hmm
how long have you been down here in skid
row uh almost three weeks now
from where memphis tennessee yeah oh you
came straight from memphis yeah
well yeah i mean i came from memphis but
like i said i went to oklahoma state a
couple days and
you know i'm 40 on all the way out you
know and
every city i'd stop and try to cough you
know i was getting sick and i had to
stop and
hustle up you know but uh yeah i had
some good luck and bad luck i overdosed
and uh
in phoenix i wasn't there ten minutes
man i pulled over
and uh you know i always try to be
careful you know but
you can't really be careful with that
needle and uh i had the narcan ready but
man
we got he got pretty close man somebody
walked up on me thank god and hit me
with a narcan
but uh and it's just it's a scary drug
you know but
i got the mind thing where i don't give
a [ __ ] you know it's just it's [ __ ]
what happens that happens you know but
what do you think
gave you that attitude uh i don't know i
think just living i don't know man
sometimes i get down on how living but
i just uh i've always had every i guess
this lifestyle i don't know what it is
though i mean not a [ __ ] attitude you
know what i'm saying i gotta keep it but
not having your dad around not having a
mom that was
present i think you know there's always
that void you know they're like
it's different now since they're past
you know i don't feel as bad after
they're gone i guess they both pass like
from drugs my mom died
you know liver failure and stuff like
that
it's a little different these days but
now i feel more like
i gonna be with them for some crazy ass
reason you know
how about your siblings how are they
doing oh my brother he's in prison
he's a meth addict my sister is a meth
addict she's uh
she's actually going through a divorce
right now because of the drug
she uh she she's the kind of person
uh like she tried lying to me about it
you know how she knows my my life and
stuff and uh
i don't know i hate seeing it you know
because she was actually the cleanest
one in the family you know for the
longest time like
she's never been in jail she's never you
know
and it's all falling apart on and i hate
you know i told her
you know i mean i told her i was like
look at me you know i'm saying like
just stop say i don't know what you're
talking about but she's
skinny as a real and you know just it's
like [ __ ] and she thinks she's the
baddest thing
you know i'm saying that drug is just
mess really not my thing i do it this is
what happens when i mess with this man
this girl got in my face popping down
pimples man and i'm out
she was wired up and uh every time i do
it i regret it but i keep on [ __ ]
doing it
i can't tell you how many times and i've
looked in the mirror and said never
again
so you'll play around with other drugs
too oh yeah but in fact
yeah yeah you tried crack as well yeah i
have how do you compare crystal math
cracking
crack uh the crack the rush
that's the only thing that crash got
like the myth these days
it's uh you're just awake you know like
you're
you're speedy but i just feel like i'm
just awake
like uh opiates speeding me up and
method kind of like leveled me out
crackle leveled me out you know i'm like
i'm speeding but i'm you know i'm saying
i'm focused
it's kind of like uh taking an adderall
i guess you know people prescribed
adderall i just
stay focused but like uh heroin god i
can
i work math off on heroin you know but
if i was depending on
then i was a little different then i'll
just kind of
he'll throw you for a [ __ ] look man
you'll be just you'll do it and
you'll be in another [ __ ] land like
it's it's different
you think it's more likely you'll die
from your addiction than
recover from it
i don't know i mean i could leave your
name you know
i don't know that's sad to say it really
is but
i really don't know how are you how do
you support yourself man
oh man i uh literally everything man
i uh hustled on whatever
i keep my eye open i keep my air open on
any kind of horse i can jump on
or intervene with something or boost
uh but i mean i'm trying these days not
to
do nothing bad i'm trying to like not
catch enough feeling i'm trying not to
go back to prison
you know but hell it's it's hard you've
done some prison time
oh yeah yeah i've done almost 14 years
in all i've improved that's all right
and you're 40. uh 37 37 i thought you
said you were 40.
yeah um do you have kids yes
yeah i have uh five baby moms six kids
yeah were you around for any of them
no well for uh the first two i was
around until they're about five or six
uh my daughter i was around until she
was about
one or two but no not really they uh
this past time i got out they want to
see me out of prison and i was i stayed
out for the longest
i was trying i kept a job for about
seven months i was on my ankle monitor
and uh i was doing my hardest and uh
that's kind of what brought me back out
here i think it's just now
not be able to would you describe
yourself as self-destructive
yeah when i'm not around them yeah
this lifestyle kind of it goes hand in
hand isn't
is this lowest point of your life yeah
i just heard that the other night
i just said that the other night i swear
to god
appreciate it
i made a joke of it i was going up the
elevator i spin the floor
i thought look that's me
and i can joke about the next day but i
cry about it now
yeah it's hard what about what emotions
do you go through living this life
probably depressed right depression
mainly other than that i keep it held in
like this came out this barely comes out
yeah
you don't get many opportunities to talk
about this kind of stuff do you no but
he goes crazy
you're so busy with uh you know trying
to get out
where do you stay now i got a truck it's
parked up in a parking garage
but uh it got tore up some guys went in
and rated it and tore up all the
paneling and uh
stole my battery mean the wheel is
still on thank god but i've been trying
to hustle up for a battery but it seems
like the drug is more important
it's been almost a week and still
still sitting there i probably owe about
200 hours worth of [ __ ] parking fees
but
i don't know i'm gonna do it i'll figure
it out when you were in prison before
did you get clean
yeah no i cleaned for a while but i
always find a way you know
you get out and you relapse oh yeah
immediately like the longest time was
this past
time you know i was out cause i was like
monitored i was doing uh well no i
i [ __ ] off a lot a couple of times i
know i did some
i did some blow and uh i didn't do no
heroin because it was a different area
and i didn't know nobody
and cocaine was around and my sister had
some over and that you know
i used but i i never felt a drug test
did not
but no i wasn't really just clean i
guess i guess pretty much lie to myself
but it's
the best i've ever been yeah
so barbie i used uh about four or five
times
that whole seven months
you know you have any friends no
i mean i did but they're all they're all
gone
i actually just uh i got shot like i
said a couple of months ago and
lost a couple friends in and lost my
life i had five buddies i grew up with
enough
just lost to life too they passed
yeah they got shot
yeah i got shot at the shoulder
something i shot in the face
they got hit the arm came out of my
chest right here
the nine millimeter and the girl's wish
she got a flesh woman she still lives
but my
my buddy's got i gotta get around to
that in fact
but i know i don't really i don't really
have none i got a home girl that's
outside
she uh i just actually ran into her man
in uh north hollywood
i met her in vegas five years ago and
she's still out here too old [ __ ] you
know
it's just crazy what are you worried
about
these days it's getting ah
just getting high and trying not to just
get hot really
what is your what's your day look like
your typical day you wake up in the
morning wake up
feel like complete total [ __ ] if i don't
have anything and
start walking start trying to figure out
how to
make the next dollar you know so you
you'll wake up without a dollar in your
pocket so
yeah yeah i'll wake up and so you need
to figure out how to get money together
yeah because
they're lately messing down here it's uh
it's hard you know it's overpicked here
like i gotta i gotta find a new area
you know i don't know why i ended up
here you know but uh
it seemed like good luck at first
because when i first got here hell i
found a whole eight ball of [ __ ]
fitting all that on the sidewalk
first i went here ten minutes and i
found the whole eight ball fitting off
so i was like hell yeah you know but the
hustling has picked over man there's so
much with so many people
like i said i traveled north hollywood
to try to make some money you know and
it didn't
look good you know it's it's so it's
god it's everywhere down here you know
like i need to go
midwest i think cause like the hustling
is uh
you'll die out here you know if you
intervene with somebody's [ __ ] hustle
yeah yeah i've been uh i've been jumped
three times
i've been shot at and i've been almost
stabbed since i've been here i've been
here
you know like almost three weeks and if
you're interviewing i don't care if
you're making ten dollars twenty five
dollars
standing there hell either way yeah
you know they're causing people getting
mugged no i don't go out trying not to
go out too late around here
you know it uh the night it gets
dangerous yeah it gets bad
yeah i was actually uh walking off the
store that night man
there was a shootout bad shoot out there
and i thought it was just more fireworks
you know they've been doing fireworks
crazy lately and uh
it wasn't man it was it was a laser
shootout i ran i ran up to the elevator
like it was man it was wild
yeah it's off it's rough but what would
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
just
don't give up don't give up
and just if you're doing good stay that
way
because you don't want to
you don't want this all right john thank
you so much for sharing your story
all right i wish you the best of luck
out there thank you
you